I'm going to come at this from the other
direction and read a piece so as a
professor I've seen many art students
you know set out to make an artwork
about loneliness and society or the
environmental crisis and their work
functions more like a research project
than as corny as this may sound an
emotional outpouring from their soul I
have tried to work this way but I think
that my most successful where it comes
from something more akin to the music
writing process for musical composers I
imagine that they hear a tune in their
head and then play the tune into
existence there are images in my head
that haunt me like waking dreams until I
manifest them in the physical world when
I was raped on the first day of my
sophomore year at Columbia University by
a classmate who turned out to be a
serial rapist I and two of the other six
women who were assaulted by him reported
our assaults to the school and the
police we wanted to keep our classmates
safe but we were met with so much
pushback that we realized that our
aspart our aspirations were futile it
felt terrible that feeling made me
imagine visualized myself carrying a
mattress and I had no idea why I just
saw this image when I finally decided to
do it and carry a mattress at Columbia I
realized that the mattress represented
the weight of the assault the subsequent
tweet the subsequent treatment by the
school and the NYPD and the constant
fear the other survivors and I shared of
seeing our attacker on campus art
creates a space for our fantasies to
take shape when there is no room for
them in the rigid status quo of reality
it's what allowed me to take the massive
feelings I'd stuffed down deep inside me
and externalize them as something
tangible concrete and while still big
and on
much more manageable shouldn't Woody
Allen have kept it that way too he could
have exercised his pedophilic desires in
Manhattan so that he didn't have to
manifest those desires in the real world
Roman Polanski should have been
satisfied with his rape fantasies in the
highly aestheticized realm of his film
art failed for them because it wasn't
enough they needed more art is separate
from the artist insofar as it stays art
it should be this way because it creates
a realm for play that can be distinct
from reality I think that certain
creators fail to maintain that
distinction and allow their desires to
bleed into the rest of their lives in
these cases it wasn't we who failed to
make the distinction between artist and
author it was they this is why when we
debate these works it is so hard to keep
the discussion quarantined in the realm
of abstract theory it's why when we as
viewers view these films we are haunted
by the uncanny feeling that the film's
did not successfully fulfill those
directors desires art is and should
remain home to the things that couldn't
have happened otherwise
you